tras una mejora en los procesos de
producción la farmacéutica pfiezer
biotech ha anunciado que distribuirá a
75 millones de dosis adicionales a la
unión europea a partir del 15 de febrero
después de algunos problemas en la
planta de fabricación de bélgica de la
farmacéutica que había ralentizado la
distribución provocando el pánico en
algunos países finalmente la compañía ha
asegurado que ya está dispuesta a
distribuir todas las dosis necesarias
por la unión europea en total la
comisión europea tiene contratadas 600
millones de dosis con pzifer además la
comisión europea ha anunciado que por el
momento ya se ha distribuido 18 5
millones de dosis y que se podrá cumplir
el objetivo que de aquí a septiembre ya
se hayan distribuido 600 millones de
dosis después de una semana pasada en
que la comisión europea le han arreciado
las críticas después de los problemas
con astrazéneca y también críticas a su
gestión en la comisión europea estaba
ávida de buenas noticias y de hacer
'borrón y cuenta nueva'
por el momento ya se ha aplicado el
nuevo mecanismo de las vacunas desde el
pasado fin de semana
las vacunas que se fabriquen en suelo
europeo solo se podrán exportar con la
previa autorización de los países
europeos